las numerosas críticas y protestas en
francia no cambiarán nada el proyecto de
ley de seguridad global fue aprobado en
primera lectura he aquí el resultado del
escrutinio votantes 558 participaron 492
mayoría absoluta 247 a favor 388 en
contra 104 este fue un gran sí para todo
el texto y en particular el artículo 24
que prevé la penalización de cualquier
difusión considerada maliciosa de
imágenes de agentes de la policía se
prevé un año de prisión y 45.000 euros
de multa para los defensores de la ley
se trata de proteger ante toda la
policía y su identidad especialmente en
las redes sociales
suponemos que contamos con los agentes
con los policías nacionales y los
policías municipales para proteger a los
franceses que en su gran mayoría apoyan
a las fuerzas de seguridad sin embargo
hoy nadie puede negar que se trabaja en
condiciones cada vez más difíciles y que
las redes sociales no ayudan por eso
hemos decidido legislar sobre este tema
para la izquierda y los guardianes de
las libertades públicas es una nueva
derivación de autoritarismo por parte
del gobierno
según ellos la ley imposibilitará el
control de la policía el objetivo ahora
es bastante claro se está poniendo en
marcha un régimen autoritario cuyo fin
es controlar a todos todo el tiempo en
todas partes la votación se produjo
horas después de varios actos de
violencia por parte de las autoridades
en parís contra un grupo de emigrantes y
un periodista violencia que ha salido a
la luz gracias a la publicación de
vídeos en twitter